néanmoins les césar c'est une académie
j'ai pas dit que c'était l'académisme
blaise est une des clés des mii vous
êtes très très loin de ça et de savoir
qu'à un moment à partir de 2013
il commence à vous aimer est ce que ça
vous a pas inquiété
je me suis dit je vieillissais mais vous
savez le goût des gens c'est de faire le
talent d'un artiste est souvent le goût
des gens qui changent donc ça fait 25
ans que j'ai avec mes petits films
beaucoup d'hommes et s'habituer est ce
que c'est parce que c'est la résignation
à ce que c'est de lassitude
est-ce que c'est du charmant
d'équipement j'en sais rien encore une
fois que sa gentille
d'autant plus qu'ils me laissent garder
mes distances par rapport à ça mais non
c'est objectivement c'est oui voilà
c'est si gentil puis à des acteurs des
actrices comme ça il ya eu des
techniciens comme ça que j'apprécie
beaucoup
donc voilà c'est sympathique mais c'est
vrai qu'il faut entendre spectateurs il
faut pas considérer que le mieux c'est
ce qu'on vous montre dont on vous dit
que c'est mieux ça faut pas tomber dans
cette erreur là en tant que jeunes
spectateurs surtout il faut contester
justement les les statuts les statuts
c'est fait pour être déboulonner n'en
faut pas avoir peur de le déboulonner
voilà même pas mal quand je tomberai au
sol
[Musique]